[Music]
according to 2017 tax returns in America
over 500,000 people made a million
dollar year income in America 500,000
people made over a million dollar income
now here's a kicker Mount Everest people
say oh my gosh you know he reached the
top of Mount Everest do you know how
many people have done it out of 7
billion people 4,000 only out of 326
million people in America 500,000 people
have made a million dollar income that
means it's so much easier to make a
million dollar your income then climb
Mount ever since some people think a
million dollar your income is such a big
deal
not anymore today in America now keep
this in mind before I get into it I'm
gonna have a PDF for you I'm gonna give
you two different sides in this episode
one is gonna be the logical side I'll
give you the math the other one's gonna
be the emotional side which is a part
that most people struggle with but this
is a guy giving you this video this
message here I've never lived in a house
I've always lived in an apartment my
parents got a divorce I barely graduated
from high school I went to the u.s. army
because every counselor I had told me
military is the best way for you because
you can go to the army you can come out
be a cop or five Friday and you'll be
set with a pension would benefits with
all this other stuff and you don't need
to worry about everything else because
schooling and success for everybody else
is not gonna work for some other like
you Patrick so I wonder military route
no.1 my family's ever made over six
figures we've never owned or lived in a
house with a swimming pool or backyard
nothing we've never owned a condo that
I've lived in ever okay so that was my
life fast-forward the moment I figured
out this formula and I trusted it this
formula and I trust which I'm gonna
share with you and by the way this is
not one of these clickbait go on this
webinar because I'm gonna show you this
program that for only $19.99 and you buy
this program i'ma show you how to be a
millionaire this is free content to you
but it's gonna make you Millions you'll
see by the time I'm done this formula
got me a Ferrari a Lambo you know
Porsche a Don or Rolls Royce a house a
15,000 score for I've traveled all over
the place more importantly family my
dad's been all over the world I've
surprised my dad my mom in the craziest
way that they couldn't even believe and
more than
anything else outside of all this other
stuff when family need of money money's
in the bank account when I wanted to
experience unique moments where people
that matter to me the most money's in
the bank account when I wanted to be
able to do things when crisis happened
for people on my family I had money in
the bank account you're watching this
listen to me you will do better for the
world being a millionaire than doing
better for the world somebody making
3040 thousand dollars per year you you
need to figure out a way how to make a
million dollar income because it is that
important to make that kind of money
today because it's free to figure out a
way to do it today and I'm gonna give it
to you now let me get into it before I
do questions thoughts comments comment
below and if you haven't subscribed to
the number one channel on youtube click
on the subscribe button for
entrepreneurship once we cross a million
subs we're doing our first live event
with all the value tenors around the
world makes your clips to subscribe
button and join a notification squad
okay so let's get right into it
so there are two areas that you need to
figure out in order for you to make a
million dollar your income one is the
logical side that has to do with math
the other one is the emotional side that
has to do with belief we'll get into
this which is going to be some unique
stuff you have not heard before but let
me explain the logic side so here's the
math side when it comes down to coins we
have a half a dollar coin $0.50 we have
a quarter twenty-five cents a dime
that's ten cents a nickel that's five
cents and a penny that's one cent right
how many different combinations of coins
makes up a dollar
here's what I mean by if I have two 50
cent half a dollar coins
that's one dollar if I have four
quarters that's a dollar five ten dimes
that's a dollar if I have 20 nickels
that's a dollar if I have 50 pennies two
quarters that's a dollar how many
combinations can I come up with to make
up a dollar you know what the number is
two hundred and ninety three different
ways I can come up with a dollar what's
my point to you to make a million dollar
your income there's so many different
ways they can break down the math to
make a million dollar income I'm gonna
give you examples on three different
industries for you to say okay now I get
it
on what I need to do to make a million
dollar your income because you gotta
know the formula on how to make a
million dollar income so let's go over
here right now mario together let's look
at the first one the first one is just
sales so pick any product that you want
to sell you don't have to it can be
insurance it can be any
you're selling that's $1,000 sale so if
your average commission is $1,000 how
many personal sales do you need to make
in a month
to make a million out of your income the
number is $1,000 is your average
Commission sale you need to make
eighty-three sales which is eighty-three
thousand dollars per month times 12
months you're making roughly a million
dollar your income that's if you sold
everything personally now you may be
watching us in st. Pat there's no way in
the world I can sell 83 these a month
that's why you may need a team or sales
team if you become a sales team if that
average sale that everybody says there's
$1,000 if your sales manager and a
broker maybe the average Commission by
sales made by a rep to you is 250
dollars which means 250 dollars if the
average sale to you is that the
Commission you make your cut you need
332 sales made by everybody to come up
with 83,000 dollars that becomes a
million dollar income so now what you're
solving for is what three hundred and
thirty-two sales how do you make three
hundred and thirty-two sales basic math
I did get five people that sell sixty
six of these products per month i
defined ten that do thirty three twenty
who do sixteen of these or get forty
sales rep that do eight of these to make
a million dollar income this is any
sales industry now looks like a real
estate here's real estate say the
average home you sell it's five hundred
thousand dollars the commission that's
paid to you as an agent is six percent
your cut the total Commission is thirty
thousand dollars your cut is 70 percent
70 percent of that thirty thousand
dollar Commission because your broker
keeps the 30 percent that's $21,000 you
need to make four of those sales per
month to make eighty four thousand
dollars a month times 12 months you make
a million eight thousand dollars per
year now you may say well my average
home size is not half a million dollars
it's a quarter million dollars no
problem you need eight sales well the
average home size I sell is a million
not alone they need to sales it doesn't
matter
figure out the math for yourself if
you're a broker and you have real estate
agents working for you how much total do
you need to sell for you to make your
30% cut of a million dollar income
here's what it is if the Commission's
$30,000 your cut
30% that's $9,000 you take as a broker
which means you need 10 sales to be made
that's $90,000 for a total of a million
80,000 per year right so how do you
break that down well you need five real
estate agents per month that make two
sales a month for you at a half a
million dollars to make 90 grand a month
or you need ten real estate agents that
work for you that make a sale of a half
a million dollars per month for you to
make a million eight per year the
formula is there now here's another one
some of you guys that are engineers you
run an IT firm or consulting firm and
the average hourly is a hundred and
fifty dollars this could be a law firm
this could be an IT from this could be
consulting firm but the average hour
that you charge I come to you I need you
to design this software for me you say
it's gonna be around 300 hours 300 hours
times 150 hours $150 per hour I'm paying
you $45,000 I'm just kind of giving you
Matthew and a $450,000 I'm giving a
Matthew you're right so if the average
hour is 150 your engineer that works for
you because you sold the contract
there's a lot of people that sell these
contracts who don't know anything about
coding or IT they sell the contract if
the average engineer who works for you
make $75 your cut is $75 that means you
need roughly 1100 hours in a month to
make eighty three thousand dollars per
month to make a million dollar income so
the formula you solve for is what 1100
hours
so 1100 hours divided by four weeks is
roughly two hundred seventy five hours
that's 40 hours per week with seven
consultants if you have seven
consultants doing 40 hours a week of you
making $75 per profit on the hour you
are making a million dollar income do
you see what I'm showing you here this
is the mathematical formula by the way
this is boring but it's exciting when
you get a paper and pen you start
writing out your format oh my gosh this
is all I need to do make a million
dollar income what do I need to do make
two million or three million or five
million or ten million that's the pure
math it's so easy to do but this is
logic this will not get it done I know a
lot of smart intelligent illogical
people with four-year degrees who met
you know mastered calculus precalculus
who have this down but they have
problems with this next part and by the
way this
this is 20% of the work this is 80%
let's get on to the emotion set so
here's the emotion side on the emotion
side you have multiple different areas
let me start off with the first one here
and this is by far the biggest challenge
people have and that is belief in order
for somebody to make this kind of money
million-dollar income you're not gonna
make it if you don't believe it so you
say well Pat how do I get a chance to
believe this I never in my wildest
dreams nobody my family made this kind
of money I've not been around people
that make this kind of money how can I
make this kind of money here's the
kicker you need to master the art of
future truth now what is future truth a
lot of people have a hard time with this
let me explain so imagine if you have a
lot of doubt you don't believe in you
right you're like I don't know about
this you know this is great but me
making a million dollar income I don't
know about that yesterday I had 60
people here in my office and I said what
is the big deal about making a million
dollar income should have seen some
people's face as well I don't really
know if I'll ever make it but it's kind
of cool to dream about having a big
house and the cars and the freedom and a
few million in the bank account but I
don't know if it's for me that's because
they don't believe in it that's because
they don't understand the concept of
future truth let me explain to you the
future truth concepts some of you may
never heard of uture truth before here's
what it is if you're going to lie about
you you may as well tell a big lie to
yourself over and over and over again
now at first it's very difficult let me
describe this to you before you get
uncomfortable for instance I am going to
make a million dollar or your income now
I want you to say it say it to me real
quick stop say it
I'm gonna give you a second say it I am
going to make a million dollar your
income say it again perfect let me ask
you was it uncomfortable do you feel
like you're lying to yourself right
sometimes people show up at a counter
was weird I feel like I'm lying to
myself if you say I am amazing I meant
to do something big with my life I'm the
guy that's going to go out and be the
hero to my family that's difficult for
some people because they're a line but
it's not a it's a current lie but it's
not a future life it's a future truth it
is a current lie but it's a future truth
you see the more you tell a big lie to
yourself
over and over and over and over and over
again and eventually believe it future
truth is you're gonna make a million
dollar income this is a belief system
that is very difficult for most people
to do because most people think every
kind of lie is a bad light no I'm not
telling you to go lie to your wife about
something's you're doing on the side or
light your husband about what you're
doing on the side
I'm telling you tell a good lie I'm
gonna make a difference in the world and
you don't believe it but say 2 million
times you're gonna end up believing it
I'm meant to do some special in my life
there's no way in the world God put me
on this planet to just be a regular guy
no way the blood in here is boiling I
want to do something big with my life
this guy was put on this planet to make
a difference say it over and over and
over and over and over and over again
convince everybody in the world the
entire team you're just trying to
convince one person and that is you and
that's the game of future truth and for
some of you that are maybe making $4,000
a month for the last 20 years you really
need to start lying to yourself you you
I'm talking to you you really need to
start this moment start telling a lie to
yourself on how special of a human being
you are over and don't expect anybody
else to do it for instance let me say
honey I wish you would have told me more
nicer things mom how come you don't tell
me nicer things dad how come you don't
tell me nicer things don't wait on them
start with you number two
perspective here's what I mean by
perspective sometimes you need to make
the big small did you notice how I
started a video and what did I say I
said that according to last year's tax
returns in America over half a million
people made a million dollar income I
said that then what did I say total
amount of people that a climb Mount
Everest is how many four thousand that
perspective to you made the big small
you need to do that over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again until like why am I thinking this
is such a big deal to make a million
dollar income it is not because you
finally got perspective you put things
in perspective and you're over and over
and over and over again making a big
small making a big small making a big
smile until eventually this is not a big
that we're going to do this as well
number three number three question
everything everything when your mom and
dad say something and it doesn't make
any sense
my heart and not everybody's gonna make
millions honey it's not us to make
millions don't say don't sit there and
let him say it stop them listen mom I
don't believe you dad I don't want to
believe you bro I don't want to believe
you dude I'm not with you I don't want
to buy into that concept say it to them
question them challenge them don't let
them get away with the by saying it
around you because if you sit there and
you don't question that thing that means
you bought into it that means you
believed it you got a question and stuff
you tell yourself stop yourself wait a
minute is that even true I don't believe
you you to yourself I don't believe what
you're saying but I don't want to
believe you
I'm telling that by what you just said
right now question every single thing
why do I believe this way why do I think
this way why am i wide this way is that
thinking even right why don't I even do
this we had a meeting last week with my
step this is a different meeting than
yesterday yesterday's was sales last
buttocks was staff and one of our
employees they were required every one
of them was required to read the book
principle and if they didn't read it
some of them were gonna get fired and
you know we had the meeting and I know
some people had this is harsh look
there's a few things with me I may look
like a guy on video you like and all
this other stuff working with me on a
daily basis the expectation on standard
is see I expect you to perform that's
the reason we create an incredible
environment where people love being
around but the expectation of
performance is very very high and the
pressure is very high to perform working
improve a few same person every three to
six months you don't need to be in this
company to go to a different place so I
was speaking about this and one lady
said well you know in this book what I
took away from this book was the fact
that I think sometimes in companies the
executives need to understand that
everybody's different and not everybody
you know does this and does that I said
I said ma'am stop I said did you even
read the book you know I didn't read the
book I said why is it that the first
thing you got out of the book is how you
can fix everybody around you instead of
how you can fix you you see the only way
your income is gonna grow is by focusing
all the things that you got to do on you
to improve if you fix you everybody else
around you is gonna be fine but you
gotta fix you and ask as the following
question I said here's a question for
you I said what's the most money you've
ever made in a year don't say it
publicly just think about that number
what is the most money ever made in a
year then I said go back ten years ago
how much has that income change and why
why
why has that income now changed that
much if 10 years ago you were making 16
bucks an hour 10 years later you making
16 bucks an hour why is that why is your
market you know value in the marketplace
the same thing is it everybody's folk is
it the government's fault that your
boss's fault your parents fault your
kids fault your spouse as well or your
fault
everything here comes back to you and
it's so hard to do but you got to face
the truth you ain't gonna make a million
dollar your income you don't face the
truth and realize the issues right here
and the last item to cover over here to
my left to your right is guaranteed
formula for success if you notice it's
got a little bit of green in it and it's
got a little bit of red in it because
it's a combination of emotion and logic
it's the four things I always talk about
my guaranteed formula for success that
is 100% proven for my life and other
people have taught out work out improve
outlast and out strategies again out
work out improve outlast out strategize
what you're looking on the screen here
on the screen look at those four again
what you're looking on on the screen
here which of those four things that
you're looking at the out work out
improve outlets out strategize which of
those four things do you think comes
last meaning you'll learn the latter the
latest it's out strategize why because
that requires a lot of experience it's
like you got to go through like a
general in the war right you got to go
through so many different words to learn
different strategies and what works and
what tactics work and what doesn't work
that's something you got to be working
on right however the other three out
work if a guy works 80 hours a week and
you work 40 hours a week you can't
compete with that guy if some if you
yourself are reading 234 books a month
and you develop in your mind and your
competitor is not and you only read one
or two and you study in industry
articles and all the subs and they're
not you know you're studying how to
recruit CEO CFO CEO CMOS what is the
best way to stretch this million dollar
investment that I got to make this
happen who should I talk to to be part
of a group for mentors and CEOs group
and all these who should I network with
what Comino should I be a part of who's
the best engineers IT firm to hire what
are these competitors don't what are
some of the guys that are not even in my
market if you start studying those
industries somebody else isn't it's
tough to compete with you and then
outlast some people work 80 hours a week
for a year and that's great but they
can't work 80 hours a week for three
years some Arcadia
a week for three years but you work 80
hours a week for five years you
outlasted the guy that the three years
are one year they can't compete with you
because the compounding effort favors
you so these four things that you look
at on the screen require one thing and
that's discipline and the discipline
part you don't hear a lot about that's
the things people do when nobody else
sees that's when you win again there's a
part of this that's logical there's a
part of this that's emotional let me get
to the last part here and wrap up the
session here so you got all these
different things
imagine this part here would you and I
talk and think about it this way what if
you at the end of its video what if you
watching this you said it makes sense
I'm gonna apply some of this stuff okay
I'm gonna sit down and figure out my
math I'm gonna do it okay and I'm gonna
sit down and question my beliefs I'm
gonna sit down and talk about the future
truth I'm gonna find a big lie and say
it over and over and over again by oh I
want you to tweet me your big lie on to
it or at Patrick big David tweet me your
big lie and my favorite lie I'm gonna
retweet a few of them you tweet me your
biggest lie at Patrick mid David what is
your big lie what is your future truth
you start working on your perspective
making a big small you start questioning
everything challenging you're thinking
you face the truth you make a game plan
to out work out and prove out last hour
strategize you start making a million
dollar income and you become one of
those 500,000 people in America that
make a million dollar income you may be
in another different country you're
making a million dollar income because
principles are evergreen in all the
countries outside of communism and
socialism what if you apply those
concepts and you started improving what
if you did that what would happen to you
what happens if you make a million
dollar your income are you better for
your family are you better for your
community are you better for your
parents your friends your kids are you
better for society are you better for
your friends are you better for
everybody more importantly are you
better for you do you have better
doctors for you do you live in a better
community you give more money to charity
do you get more money to communities do
you feel better about yourself do you
wake up in the morning and once you
figure out this entire formula do you
really think you can go back to being a
regular person like you used to be do
you really think you can go back and
take up some of your bad habits if you
make this thing too consistent thing now
it's easy to
go back and being bad but don't you
think you're gonna start living a whole
different life is it not worth it to
make a decision to do this you see the
reality is of everybody watching this
maybe 1% of you is actually gonna apply
the things we talk maybe 1% of everybody
watching is gonna apply the stuff that
we're talking about most people are just
gonna go boom boom they skipped you went
back to work or you went back to a whole
different thing and you'll say I'm gonna
get back to this later on today put a
reminder and you forget about like
everybody else does a few of you are
gonna watch us and you're gonna say stop
everything I'm taking a break hey I need
a break 20 minute break 30 minute break
go grab it because your emotions are
high start writing start asking right
this whole for me we're gonna have a PDF
below for you to get and start writing
all this stuff if that's you I've got
two other videos for you to watch 111
skills of a millionaire the 11 skills
millionaires master you got to watch
this one and another one is how to
really become a millionaire not how to
make a million dollar and come how to
really become a millionaire you need to
watch how to really become a millionaire
you need to watch 11 skills every
millionaire masters you do those things
and go through the PDF and start
applying these concepts to 3 6 12 months
from now not only are you not gonna
recognize yourself none of your friends
and family is gonna start recognizing
yourself and all of a sudden you gonna
send me a message on Facebook Instagram
Twitter st. Pat I just cross a million
dollar income how I asked you how's it
feel how's it feel it was it as hard as
you thought it was gonna be it was hard
but not as hard as I thought it was
gonna be and I'm making a million dollar
income and by the way I can't wait for
you to do it you I'm talking to you the
serious one you I can't wait for you to
do I can't wait for your dreams to
become a reality I can't wait for it I
cannot wait for you to experience this
and tell me about it or you're two years
three years five years from now anyways
you want the PDF click on the link below
questions thoughts comment comment below
and if you haven't subscribed to the
channel click on the subscribe button
right here to my left take everybody
well bye
[Music]